foreign
[Music]
coming up we have an exclusive interview
with Matthew Knowles Beyonce's father
former producer and manager as he tries
to help British talent get a break
practice practice practice
and that has to be the main focus of
your day
every day
and we chat to mental health Ambassador
Dr Alex George about how to beat the
winter Blues
[Music]
hi we're going to start with the two
huge earthquakes that have destroyed
thousands of buildings across turkey and
Syria many people remain trapped under
the rubble but rescue teams from across
the world are working night and day to
bring people to safety
the earthquake started in the southern
Turkish city of gaziante and the
earthquake was so strong it was felt
across turkey Syria Lebanon Cyprus and
Israel experts say it was one of the
largest earthquakes recorded in that
area sadly thousands of people have died
or been injured world leaders including
the UK prime minister have said they'll
offer whatever support is needed some
countries have sent specialist teams to
help rescue people an aid such as food
and water to the worst affected areas
but how do these natural disasters
happen and is there anything we can do
to predict them and save lives well
declan's been investigating
so what causes earthquakes well I'm
going to need an expert who can tell us
and I've got just the person David
Hawthorne from the British Geological
Survey hi David hi Declan so that is a
brilliant question and it's all to do
with what we call plate tectonics so you
might feel that the ground underneath
your feet is a very stable place but
actually it's composed of these tectonic
plates so I can think of the surface of
the Earth like a giant spherical jigsaw
puzzle but these plates don't just stay
where they are they're actually moving
around and that's where the problem
comes from when those plates crash into
each other when they slide past each
other we get huge releases of energy and
that energy gets released along fault
lines and we feel that energy as
earthquakes
so most of the earthquakes happen along
the fault lines yeah that's right Declan
uh the most earthquakes do happen along
fault lines because that's where all the
energy is being released so places like
Japan where one plate is being pushed
under another or places like America
where you're also getting lots of
earthquakes
so that must be quite scary for the
people living in those places yeah it's
definitely scary particularly the first
time you're ever in an earthquake but
for lots of countries that have really
big dangerous earthquakes they've got
really clever about dealing with them so
they have fantastically designed
buildings that can withstand earthquakes
and even children who are in school will
be trained and drilled on a regular
basis to make sure that they're as safe
as possible when there is an earthquake
but they can still be really dangerous
right yes yes they can there's no
getting away from that so you've
probably seen in the news after a big
earthquake somewhere and you've heard
people talking about the Richter scale
and how damaging it was well the Richter
scale is a way of measuring what we call
the magnitude of an earthquake so the
biggest ever earthquake had a magnitude
of 9.5 and that happened in Chile in
South America the biggest earthquake
we've ever had here in Britain was was a
magnitude of 6.1 and that happened in
the North Sea more than a hundred years
ago well thank you so much for your time
David thanks for asking the question
Declan
singer Beyonce has made history by
becoming the biggest Grammy Award winner
ever she won four more which made it a
total of 32 throughout her career they
are the biggest award in the music
industry handed out by the recording
Academy of the United States but before
Beyonce was an award-winning solo artist
she was in a very successful band called
Destiny's Child and they were managed by
her father Matthew Knowles he's now in
the UK helping undiscovered Talent
become the next Beyonce or Destiny's
Child in an exclusive interview with
fyi's jariah he said he just wants to
give something back and help us achieve
our dreams
foreign
and then walks in your new lecturer and
Mentor
thanks everyone
he's now helping undiscovered Talent
across the country and teaching that the
london-based music College lccm who is
this young man over here
I went down to the studio to watch him
Mentor the group that was rap Collective
let's do this
[Music]
GRC
that was great thank you that was great
who could sing
want to try it just to see yeah
[Music]
you know if we had time we would we
would really get this right because I
love this song by the way I love it
that why do you Mentor so many kids
isn't there more money in bigger acts
and recording deals when you've been as
blessed as I have been and the gratitude
that I have for that
I feel it's important that I help others
should go get a record deal to yeah
record though that for me as a groupie I
want to like leave a mark isn't it a
danger that when people come to see
Beyonce's Dad they think you're going to
make them a star well I don't do that
part of it anymore I'm not a record
label anymore I'm not a manager anymore
I'm a motivational speaker I'm a teacher
I try to give them advice on where to
get managers and advice on how to get a
record deal
don't need no company just the closest
[Music]
stop
what are you saying there's no time to
waste because I'm gonna like make your
own way do you believe that yeah of
course
okay then when you sing it
make me believe that your initial
singing is critical
there's a lot of other professions
outside of this door if you're shy I
would highly suggest you pick another
profession this is not the right one for
you
and you're just wasting your time
this week how many hours did you
practice we practice
school so you practice five hours a week
I just want to give you a comparison to
Destiny's Child on the average practice
40 hours a week wow
our day will not get it
I read it took a lot of work to make
destiny
deaths in order to Beyonce as famous as
the become today why was it so tough to
be the best means that you have to make
sacrifices practice practice practice
and that has to be the main focus of
your day I grew up on a dirt road we
didn't have Plumbing I could have used
that as an excuse and I could just say
my parents are poor they're not educated
we're black in the south
or it could give me the determination
to want to be successful to better
myself not to be a victim in life well
you've done great for Where You Are by
yourself and nobody there to really
guide you
might need to find you a real manager
that can help you
put it together
hi guys hi what was the best advice he
gave you confidence confidence
confidence is key if you don't have any
confidence then you're not going to be
able to take off not whiny well try me
we're short okay please come find me but
you know
fight me
it's recently been announced that the
oil and gas company shell had a 53
increase in its profits a whopping 32
billion pounds to be exact and that's
its biggest profit increase in its 115
year history but it's not just shell
other oil and gas companies like BP have
also announced record profits it's
basically because of the pandemic and
war in Ukraine both of these things
meant that supplies of gas and oil went
down which meant that the price went up
it's led to huge profits for energy
companies but also a rising energy bills
for households and many families are
struggling to pay and loads of people
think this is so unfair Lauren McDonald
is a climate activist who's been
campaigning against the use of fossil
fuels so Lauren thank you so much for
joining us thank you for having me so it
just doesn't make sense you know these
massive profits when so many of us are
struggling financially so what do you
think needs to be done first of all what
I think needs to be done is that the UK
government needs to intervene and people
are really really struggling the UK
government are effectively handing out
Millions upon millions of pounds to to
oil companies just for deciding to go
ahead with new oil and gas Investments
so I would first of all ask the
government to stop doing that and I know
that you campaign against new oil and
gas Fields being built like the one in
Scotland Rose bank so um in the North
Sea we have oil and gas Fields dotted
around and these are platforms that are
built in the sea to then dig really deep
into the Earth's crust and extract
fossil fuels that is extracted and then
burned and which creates lots of
pollution so what we are calling on with
the stop rosebank campaign is to stop
the rose Bank oil fields and all new
fossil fuel developments the rose Bank
oil field that you mentioned
specifically is the largest undeveloped
oil field in the North Sea so we've been
checking this out and the government's
response to views like Lawrence is that
in order to limit the cost of car fuel
gas and electricity for families they
have to explore all sources of energy
right here in the UK that solar wind but
also oil and gas
the government says they believe it's
right that they have lifted the pause
and allowing more gas and oil drilling
to find any potential source of gas and
oil
they also say a decision hasn't been
made on the go-ahead for the rose Bank
oil field I would just say that we
should keep asking questions and keep
looking at what what doesn't feel quite
right it doesn't seem quite right that
this is happening well thank you for
joining us and thanks for your time
thank you so much for having me
[Music]
well for loads of us this time of year
can be really hard a combination of
post-christmas Blues and dark cold
winter weather and of course the cost of
living can make things pretty tough yeah
well good job we just had Children's
Mental Health Week to shine a light on
the help available to all of us Maya
chatted to Dr Alex George the UK's youth
mental health ambassador to find out
what we can do to help ourselves and
each other
hi Dr Alex so what are the winter Blues
the winter Blues are essentially when
people feel kind of low sad lack of
energy over the winter time what it
really means is that many of the
symptoms of depression are experienced
but over a specific time of year and the
reason that happens is because well
effectively we have less sunlight things
like vitamin D which is very important
for our bones we get from sunlight it's
also important for our brains as well
and one of the problems we have here in
the UK is that even if you do get
outside on those in those very few
moments we get Sunshine isn't enough to
get the vitamin D that we need if we're
getting anxious around this time of the
year what can we do about it if you're
feeling anxious I.E you feel Restless
irritable upset worried you're having
palpitations you feel on edge you're not
sleeping you don't feel you're enjoying
things any of those symptoms that
persist for more than a short period of
time you should be speaking to people
about that because no one wants anyone
to suffer or feel sad or feel bad you
don't have to go through these things
alone so please if you are struggling
with anxiety recognize it talk to a
trusted adult speak to a teacher talk to
your GP and talk to your friends what
are some everyday things that we can all
do to lift our mood what are the things
that makes you feel good I know for me
one of the biggest things if I'm in a
bad mood I'm feeling anxious going for a
walk going outside walking nature with
my favorite favorite tunes on is almost
guaranteed to lift my mood and it's
having those things in your back pocket
not just in the days that you feel bad
but maintaining your mental health and
feeling good I.E I go for walk every
morning those things over time in
combination can have an amazing effect
on your body if you think about what the
fundamentals are of your health
generally speaking it's your sleep it's
having some movement each day it's
eating generally well it's feeling a
sense of purpose in life it's having
friends and family around us those are
the kind of fundamental things so if you
can do a little bit for each of those
things it can make a huge difference
over time
[Music]
cheers Meyer when we heard from an
app we headed to shore Emery School in
Devon to how pupils there are fighting
the winter Blues
if you feel better in the winter when
you're sad
family walks and spending time with
family and going on like adventures in
the woods and stuff in the winter I
usually feel a bit lonely when I'm
inside I stay warm with hot chocolates
and sometimes I read under the blanket
with a head torch winter makes me feel
like annoyed to have to get up and it's
cold and dark and I have to walk to
school play with friends you don't like
stay inside all the time don't just like
spend all day like on your phone at home
because that's like not really really
good for you I prefer to go or my family
and have fun well I would say to my
friends that you can come to me or
anything or you could figure out some
games to play or sit next to a fire
watch some films make sure that you also
stay healthy eat healthy food
got side Lots Winter makes me feel like
droopy and like weird out it makes me
feel really tired because it goes dark
quicker or sad because like it's not
sunny or shining anymore yeah and it's
cold just stay positive throughout
winter one of my thing is like coloring
like sometimes it's dark and bloomy when
you color it's like bright
and I would always wear bright clothes
well that's it from us this week Tara
don't forget for more info on the news
check out all of our shows and videos on
our webpage bye
foreign